Containers were developed to solve
problems with installing and
running software across different
operating environments.
You saw the problems
of just installing and
running the applications
on a single machine.
Now imagine trying to run and
install EngineX on multiple
machines across different OSes.
It would be a nightmare.
With containers,
you get independent self-contained
packages that avoid version conflicts.
This is part of the appeal
of container images.
They're easy to distribute
because they carry all of their
dependencies with them.
Now, the point of containers is that we
want isolation from various processes.
We've already talked about
isolation of the file system level,
but there are other
kinds of isolation too.
For instance,
network isolation means that
each instance gets its own IP address.
They're all free to buy in port 80,
which is EngineX's default port,
without us having to deal with any
init scripts or startup files.
An important concept to note,
whereas two separate virtual
machines on a computer will
run two whole separate OSes,
multiple containers run in
the same operating system,
because containers are a logical
construct we use within the OS.
That's what makes them so lightweight,
and easy to start up and shut down.